I've been saying since the incident with
a [ __ ] provider Kellyanne Conway and NBC
News Chuck Todd the corporate media
should just stop interviewing Kelly Anne
Conway and over the weekend CNN did
exactly that they turned down an
interview with Kelly Anne Conway
we have an image here that I'm going to
show you a tweet from brian Stelter who
said / a CNN spokeswoman in lieu of Mike
Pence the White House offered Kelly Anne
Conway for an interview but CNN declined
so of course speculation exploded about
well why did CNN do it if it's just that
they wanted pence they were denied
access access to pence and they said no
we don't want Kelly Anne then that's
sort of one thing if it's because
they've come to agree that Kelly Anne
Conway is such a serial liar that nobody
should be giving her airtime then I
actually happened to agree with that but
we don't really know Kelly Anne Conway
has deflected saying cNN has not banned
me they've booked me on other shows
during the week it was some kind of
conflict blah blah blah blah blah I
maintain that a really good way to push
back against Trump's fake news claims
about CNN or about whoever is don't
interview the spokespeople who just go
around spreading nonsense like
fabricating the bowling-green massacre
out of thin air that will anger Trump
and if the trumpets are committed to the
idea that corporate media like CNN is
spreading fake news and blah blah blah
does it even really matter whether you
interview Kelly Anne Conway or not
there's much to gain by just not giving
her a platform I just think that CNN
turned her down because she seems to
always be on these cable news shows all
the time so maybe the viewers are just
getting sick of her I don't know if
they're really taking a stand here
because if they had offered Steve Bannon
or Donald Trump himself in the egg
pestis place I think they would have
jumped on that opportunity so if you
offer the president when they're looking
for the vice president obviously know
he's going to turn that down
Steve Bannon though would actually be a
very very interesting one and to be
clear I'm not saying no platform
Kellyanne Conway period I'm saying as a
reaction to the allegations that you
were fake news
don't provide a platform for Trump's
cronies to lie and again this has
nothing to do with saying oh I think
that unprincipled people with certain
ideas just shouldn't be allowed on ever
on and fight back do whatever you want
but merely as an active sort of
frustration or deliberately to anger
Donald Trump this is a pretty good way
to do it people who use alternative
facts and make up imaginary terrorist
attacks don't really contribute
constructively to our understanding of
what's taking place on the planet and
arguing with her may not achieve much
because the trumpets have already been
primed not to believe anything that CNN
says if only we could no platform Sean
Spicer but unfortunately he's the White
House press secretary yeah I kind of
have to hear from him
it's hard to know platform the guy who
gives daily briefings in the White House
press room where all sorts of media
outlets including allegedly soon
Infowars or present and reporting
obviously there are going to be you know
Breitbart Fox News they would never say
hey you know what
Kellyanne Conway is such serial liar
there's really no reason to be
interviewing her they're never going to
do it but if you get called out as fake
news by the president maybe you say
alright well your cronies aren't welcome
here they would love to have Kelly Kelly
and on as a regular spokesperson at
least yeah a correspondent and there's
actually there's a movement this is just
a whole crazy thing there's a movement
on line of men
I guess it's mostly men maybe some women
but from what my experience it's mostly
men who seem to be quite taken with
Kelly Ann Conway and her physical
appearance they seem to think that she
she is just an amazingly attractive
woman and they seemed smitten almost I
would say by Kelly Anne and they'd love
to see her on their television screen
yeah I guess now at that that's uh I I
think that it would be really tough
we've talked before about like could you
be with someone whose political views
are opposite yours Kelly Ann Conway is
more than just having different
political beliefs I mean she she is so
out there in every way as a political
entity that it's hard to imagine anyone
being with her romantically unless
you're completely committed to what
she's talking about on TV right exactly
you have to agree 100% and it's
interesting that Trump would choose her
as one of his spokespeople because looks
are really important to Donald Trump we
know that yeah
well maybe I mean she could be
considered an attractive woman it's not
my thing
but I know that there are people on the
Internet people are saying that they're
completely taken with her